all right uh this hopefully will be
funny informative enlightening or just
flat out fun we're gonna look at some
different trade ideas that we've come up
with we put it out on twitter
last night because our work is always
easier when someone else does it but the
test is going to be under each of these
various scenarios who puts the kibosh on
it who says
no
that's not a deal that's going to work
it could be team it could be coach could
be owner could be player could be
anybody so let's just have some fun with
that as we try this out since it is
trade season in the nfl as we saw
yesterday with carson wentz and the
colts and the eagles doing business one
thing i need to mention one thing i need
to mention before we go any further
remember none of these deals are done
until march 17 at 401 pm eastern and as
we see more and more miles of these
deals that get done in advance
statistically
at some point it's inevitable that one
of them is not going to happen that one
of them is going to fall apart and and
all it takes is a failed physical that's
all it takes that's the easy cover sorry
we wanted to go forward but the doctor
didn't feel comfortable and failed the
physical it's going to happen at some
point you can't have this many deals
that are done weeks in advance of when
the deals become official and not
inevitably have one of them go sideways
and the minute we stop saying that
is the minute it's going to happen
yeah probably but i i don't know that
it's going to happen with the highest of
profile deals right because you don't
trade these quarterbacks and then think
well something might happen or something
might not happen and
you you have to have complete confidence
i think with whether you're trading matt
stafford and jared goff or whether
you're trading carson wentz to
indianapolis that this is going to go
through from a physical standpoint you
can't come in at the 11th hour and then
say i don't know i'm maybe having some
buyers or more failed invisible like
that if that were to happen and
obviously it would become something that
is a huge huge story but it also i think
would damage the reputation of whatever
team it is so that teams across the
league probably wouldn't want to deal
with that team anymore so i think you're
right it's probably going to happen at
some point but it will be something
that's a maybe lower profile deal
something for maybe like a fourth round
pick or a fifth round pick as opposed to
top quarterbacks that are supposed to be
franchise guys
important disclaimer to make before we
embark on this journey these proposed
deals are completely and totally
fabricated and will always be treated
that way
by nbc sports and all affiliated
companies and subsidiaries we will never
take this and turn it into a suggestion
that that it's a report that this is a
trade that could be done such as for
example oh i don't know just something
random desean watson to the panthers for
three first round picks and christian
mccaffrey we will never present that as
anything other just some crazy
concoction i don't know why i'm saying
that i just am let's get into it
seahawks quarterback russell wilson
to the jacksonville jaguars
for
the first overall pick in the draft the
trevor lawrence pick or whatever you
want it to be
and two additional
first round
selections if that trade is on the table
who
would say no to it remembering that
russell wilson does indeed have a no
trade clause miles
uh i would say basically anybody
affiliated with the seattle seahawks
would say no to that so russell wilson
uh owners
pete carroll schneider you know whoever
you wanted to be with the seattle
seahawks i think they would say no
because i don't think they want to get
rid of russell wilson i don't think
russell wilson inherently wants to leave
seattle either i think he just wants
things to improve where he is and think
about going from pete carroll somebody
who you know can get you to super bowl
to then go into urban meyer who yes he's
had plenty of success at the college
level but i don't think you can say that
he's gotten through his first few weeks
as an nfl head coach unscathed so
i if i'm anybody with seattle i would
say no but if anybody with jacksonville
i think i would say yes
yeah look i i i am not ready to say that
anyone with seattle would say no to this
russell wilson may say no to it russell
wilson may say
sorry i don't want to play for the
jacksonville jaguars although he may be
intrigued by the trips to london every
year right he may he may find that
intriguing but i i don't think he's
going to want to play for the jaguars i
think he'd be the one who would nix it
but seattle more broadly and i go back
to 2018 and this is something that chris
sims talked about before anyone else and
now plenty of others are talking about
it the the notion that the seahawks were
pondering the possibility of sending
russell wilson to the browns for the
first overall pick in 2018 with the idea
that they would have taken josh allen so
here we are
three years later a quarterback in
trevor lawrence that
has some comparisons to a josh allen
type of of a guy big guy mobile guy
big arm
if that landed on the seahawks desk
right now at a time when they're paying
russell wilson 35 million a year and
they're not all that far from his agent
saying time for the next contract that
puts him at the top of the market time
to do it time to make it happen
when you look at all those factors
i could see the seahawks being intrigued
by it now now look some think the
passage of a week with no further issues
or problems with the seahawks have
caused everything to kind of resolve i
don't think anything's been resolved i
think it's still where it was last week
so
i think that it's more likely that
russell wilson would say no to it but if
i'm the seahawks and i can get the first
overall pick
and two more jaguars first round picks
which are likely to be higher than lower
as they rebuild this team
i i'm seriously thinking about it again
i think that the the quarterback
involved is the one who would be most
likely to say no but i i think the
seahawks would be intrigued if that
offer was on the table i might not be
intrigued but i don't think that that
kits them to a championship caliber
level
like that they would still be if they
had russell wilson i mean obviously if
you have a qb on a rookie contract that
allows you to then build around the qb
and set you up to then be a super bowl
contender or like if you want to give
good pieces on defense if you want to
sign some veteran offensive lineman and
make sure that qb is protected you want
to go out and get a good wide receiver
and make sure you can pay that guy as
well but
i don't know i i always just think that
the qb is so important and you know
we've always talked about how russell
wilson's never gotten an mvp vote and
then he had the great start to the year
that then turned into an okay finish and
then they lost in that first round of
the playoffs to the los angeles rams i
just don't know why if you're seattle
you'd want to replace your veteran qb
with a rookie qb and then still think
that without training him you can get to
where you really want to get to i just
think that having that veteran qb and
having somebody who has won you a super
bowl before is a much easier way of
getting to a championship level than
trying to bring in an unknown and
figuring out whether or not they can do
it for you but you know hey i i'm not a
seattle decision maker so what what do i
know
when did they get to the super bowl
what what contract was russell wilson
operating under he no he was on the
turkey deal yes i know i thought of that
as i was saying it too that's a good
point but they also had they also had
the nucleus of a great team around him
right now i don't think they have that
yeah they have jamal adams but let me
tell you if russell wilson ever gets
traded i think the next guy who's going
to be jostling for a trade because we
know how much he wants to win games and
all of a sudden the seahawks may not be
winning many games without russell
wilson it's going to be jamal adams
another russell wilson trade and this is
one that peter king mentioned last
friday seahawks sent wilson to the jets
for
sam darnold
the number two overall pick in this
year's draft and two additional first
rounders so you get darnold plus three
ones including the first pick after the
trevor lawrence pick does that change
your thinking in any way i know it does
for me because i think russell wilson
more intrigued by the possibility of new
york than jacksonville all due respect
to jacksonville
but would the seahawks think of this one
any differently in your mind
i think that they should and one reason
is just because you have a quarterback
who at least has some experience playing
i think we know what sam darnold can be
you know when he's good he's really good
now does he have you know some turnover
problems yes he also does but i think
russell wilson wouldn't be as quick to
say no to this one as he would be for
that jacksonville trade and i think that
this one makes more sense to me from a
seattle perspective too because i mean
you're not getting the number one
overall pick but you're getting the two
overall pick you're getting another
couple first round picks that have the
potential to be higher than not and at
least you're getting a quarterback back
you know who already has played some
games in the league so
uh
the game is who says no i still would
say russell wilson would say no to this
one
but i think he wouldn't say no as
quickly as he would with a trade to
jacksonville if that makes any sense
no i i i agree with you on that i just
think that it's going to take something
huge if it ever even happens and and the
the seahawks clearly have gotten calls
but so far they have deflected any
interest i think next year is the more
likely boiling point for team and player
based on how 2021 goes but uh a couple
of intriguing thoughts and possibilities
that who knows look that's the the one
thing that we've learned about the nfl
you can't rule out anything so
everything is on the table here's one
and this is the first one that was on
the table for the texans when word came
out that deshaun watson wants out the
first team we heard about was the
dolphins so it became a very simple
proposition of
tua
being sent from miami to houston now as
we've structured this possibility it's
two of us three first-round draft picks
and we know one of the picks the
dolphins have is the third overall
selection
from the texans for the laramie tunsil
trade
who would say no to two uh plus three
ones for deshaun watson
it might be jack easterby or nick
casario but i don't know if anybody
should i think that that's probably the
most fair deal that they would get to
sean watson i don't think would say no
to it two would talk about lola might
want to say no to it but i don't know
that he really has much of a say in this
but that to me is a deal that really
sets up miami very well and at least if
you're houston
that's a trade that gets you back a
quarterback who is drafted within the
top 10
who can be an elite quarterback maybe if
you train him up properly and i think it
at least sets you up with a quarterback
that's on a rookie contract that you can
build around and say look yes we got rid
of deshaun watson but we also got back
somebody who we think has a lot of
potential somebody who we've seen win
national championships at alabama and
you know what maybe that's something
that you could sell to them but at least
at this point it seems like you know the
the top brass of the texans would say no
to it but i think it's a deal that they
probably should seriously consider
saying yes to
i i think that that the dolphins would
say no to this deal as constructed three
ones and tua seems like too much what
what i would rather do and i i i
remember suggesting the possibility of
two are going somewhere else and then
the compensation for two are flowing
back through to the texans but i just
feel like two and three ones is more
than what the dolphins should give up
for deshaun watson but then again you
have desean watson i mean that what is a
franchise quarterback
not even in his prime yet he's still
early in his career he's still ascending
what is he worth now i'm talking myself
out of it i don't know if you're the
dolphins i think you give up whatever
you have to give up to get him as long
as it doesn't undermine your ability to
win now that's the problem if you're
deshaun watson
and that's one of the original
challenges we flagged when we look at
where desean watson could go
you don't want to go to a team that when
they give up what they give up to get to
sean watson turns that team into the
texans because there's nothing left
that's that's the challenge but i think
that the dolphins could get away with
two uh plus three ones especially since
one of the ones
is the first round pick that came from
houston i think they could get away with
that given the team they currently have
and still be in great position to
contend so
maybe reluctantly the dolphins
say yes
to two or plus three ones it just seems
a little heavy but maybe it is worth it
when you consider what you're getting
into sean watson so i've changed my mind
okay
i'm saying do the deal today do the deal
today we need content we need page views
for the weekend do it today dolphins and
texans i mean i think we can kind of
live off the carson woods trade for at
least another day that's true that's
true listen i am
i want to milk the cow completely that
we have in the barn so don't anyone i'm
saying no more trades we we between ben
roethlisberger being on thin ice in
pittsburgh and carson when's gone we've
got all we need for the weekend save it
until monday no more 11 p.m eastern
saturday night trades rams and lions
save it to monday please
sorry
that's what i'm saying look if the
dolphins have the third pick that when
you mention this they got from the
laramie tunzel trade i think that's part
of why you can say you give up your
first round this year basically it's 2-1
then you give up tua because you're
getting the franchise quarterback back
and then next year's one to me that's
not too much of a price to pay for a
quarterback who can set you up for maybe
the next 10 to 15 years you already know
he's playing at an elite level mike and
like you just said
he's somebody that you know if he's
maybe not even entering his prime yet
he's probably not even in it so if you
can get that kind of quarterback i might
even throw a fourth first round pick in
there just because that gives you that
kind of stability and so what you have
to then do is say all right we've got to
draft and develop from the second to
seventh round much better than we might
otherwise because we don't have that
first round pick but if you're a good
enough personnel office i think you can
do that the rams have shown that they
can at least kind of do that they keep
going back to the playoffs even though
they haven't had a first round pick
since jared goff literally in 2016.
there's a way to do it and a way to do
it well and like i said if i'm miami i
might even say throwing a fourth first
rounder in there antua give me deshaun
watson and we might be in a good
position to contend for years and years
and years
see mahoney 23 on twitter suggests
another desean watson scenario watson to
the broncos for quarterback drew locke
linebacker von miller two first round
picks and two second round picks who
says no
to that one miles
um i think that the texans probably
would say no to that one and i think
that they say no to this one
more than they say no to the previous
one with miami because they're not
getting back a quarterback who has as
high of a ceiling i think tua's ceiling
is probably significantly higher than
that of drew locke and honestly they
kind of seem like about the same guy i
think that to his team down there in
miami is a little bit better than the
one that drew lock has got up there in
denver
but
i think drew lock has some traits
but i i don't know that he's going to be
the type of quarterback that you say all
right i know that we're getting somebody
who's established for deshaun watson and
the other thing is with von miller yay
don't know how healthy he's going to be
and b you don't necessarily know exactly
what he's going to be
in terms of what you have to pay him now
they've got to somehow work that out
there um in denver and i think we talked
about it yesterday where the agent and
the team have necessarily had contact
yet but i think if you're jack easterby
if you're nicosia i don't know that that
deal intrigues you as much as some of
the others that we've been talking about
mike
here's why it intrigues me if i'm the
texans i go back to december 2019.
i think i've talked about this a couple
of times this week drew
for the broncos had a texans team that
would make it to the playoffs the
broncos were not good at all the win
over the texans made them five and eight
drew lock in a 38-24 victory was
phenomenal von miller told reporters
after the game of lock he's a bleeping
rock star that was the buzz lightyear
game i remember talking to you about
that now because we established that you
were around you were alive for buzz
lightyear which is very very uh
at least relieving to me for a little
bit but um i i think that that intrigues
the texans now david cully the coach
wasn't there nick casario the gm wasn't
there but easter b and cal mcnair the
guys who were running the team were
there they witnessed it so
you you have the young guy who's got
potential that has not yet been
fulfilled you've got von miller who
comes in with uh you know some sizzle
some pizzazz although he was injured all
last year and you get multiple picks for
it
i i i kind of like this trade i kind of
like this for everyone i don't know who
says no to it
especially because we've seen the
reports and the suggestions that desean
watson is intrigued by the broncos and
for good reason they've got a great
collection of skill position players and
and what have they been searching for
since winning super bowl 50 the answer
at quarterback
i'm very fascinated by what george
payton the new gm of the broncos could
concoct and we've seen the report as
well that they plan to pursue
deshaun watson if the texans decide to
trade him i think they should pursue him
even if they don't decide to trade him
because i think that's what it's going
to take it's going to take offers it's
going to take pressure and it's going to
take putting the texans in a situation
where they are getting something that
they can't refuse and hopefully they'll
be smart enough to not refuse it another
broncos trade that is very fascinating
to me
kirk cousins vikings quarterback two
years left under contract at a total
payout of 56 million
cousins to the broncos for drew lock and
a second round pick who would say no to
that one miles
uh i might say no to that one if i'm the
broncos
because i don't know that kirk cousins
is really going to elevate me all that
much more than drew locke i don't know i
mean kirk cousins when he's good he's
great but when he's not he's really not
and i think if you can sort of develop
drew locke and
you think that whatever julot ceiling is
i think it might be around that of kirk
cousins um because when drew lock has
had these good games i mean you just
brought up that texans game in 2019
there was a game against the panthers
that he had in 2020 where drew locke was
really excellent when he's good he's
really good so if you can just get that
level up and make him a little bit more
consistent you've still got him on a
rookie contract for the next couple of
years maybe you can develop more around
him and get him some more skill players
so that you know like we were talking
about with russell wilson you get a guy
who can get you to the super bowl with
the amalgamation of talent that is
around rather than just with the qb i
don't know that kirk cousins elevates
you enough to get that done so i guess
to answer the question in a very long
manner uh the the broncos i think would
say no to this particular trade
i i think that
the mere fact that george payton would
or wouldn't make the call will tell us
in a roundabout way what the vikings
currently think of kirk cousins because
peyton's been there he knows he's part
and and he has an opinion on kirk
cousins so
you know
i think
the problem is the vikings need kirk
cousins to the extent that mike zimmer
wants to have a good enough of a season
to keep his job i think big picture long
term the vikings would be better off
moving on especially because cousins
made it clear he's going to play out the
final two years of his contract and the
way things work it's going to be
impossible to franchise tag him he's
hitting the market in two years now what
will the market be for him i don't know
i think that that uh
i think
i don't know i think the vikings say no
to it for that reason the vikings need
kirk cousins and i don't think drew
locke is enough of a replacement who can
come in and allow the vikings to be good
enough this year to keep people employed
that's why they want to keep kirk
cousins so they would need an upgrade
that would allow mike zimmer to think i
put this guy in place we're going to be
good enough that i get a 20 22. even if
it's in the best interest of the team to
move on from the cousin's contract and
see what you have in drew locke i don't
think locke has enough to save zimmer
after this year and that's why the
vikings would say no to it specifically
it would be zimmer saying just rick
spielman the gm hey you know what
without cousins we both may be fired
after this season all right uh here's
one from
seattle 12th fan browns receiver odo
beckham jr and a fourth round pick to
the patriots for cornerback stefan
gilmore
miles who would say no to that
oh
man
uh
i want to say the browns because i think
that they feel like if they have odell
beckham jr they can be an even better
offense than they were in 2020
but
also getting that kind of caliber corner
back
when you're getting you're getting rid
of somebody like odell beckham jr
man that's
that's a tough one to say no to i think
almost the patriots might say no to it
first because you know even if you have
odell beckham jr who's throwing him the
ball i mean are they going to go out and
somehow get jimmy garoppolo from san
francisco and then at that point who's
san francisco's quarterback and you've
sort of got this domino effect or
snowball effect there
so i think that the patriots would be
more likely to say no to it because you
don't know who's throwing him the ball
and you don't know if even having odell
beckham jr is going to make that much of
a difference for you because until you
solve the qb issue you can't really
solve anything else
first question is he healthy and that
that would be the thing that would cause
me to pause if i were the patriots if he
is healthy though it's clear that
beckham has craved playing for the
patriots now i don't know how much of it
was tom brady versus playing for the
patriots and you're right there needs to
be a good quarterback there
maybe having odo beckham jr makes the
team more attractive from a quarterback
standpoint i don't know because you know
the reality with odell beckham jr and
maybe he loses this aspect of his
overall football persona if he goes to
the patriots the idea that i need to get
the football for the team to win i need
to get the ball if i'm not getting the
ball the team's not going to win and i'm
justified in wanting the ball because i
believe that's what helps the team win
that put a lot of pressure on baker
mayfield in 2019 i think that's one of
the reasons why they struggled and look
at what happened last year without him
he gets injured against the bengals
people ask the question of various
members of the browns are you better off
as an offense without him and yeah guys
like baker mayfield weren't real happy
with that question being asked and you
know look it's right after the guy tears
an acl but it's a fair question and
i don't know they made they made it to
the final eight without him so stefan
gilmore definitely seems like a guy
who
is available
for the patriots and it looked like they
were thinking about doing something at
the trade deadline you know
this one kind of makes sense to me but i
think the big red flag is odo beckham jr
is he healthy and that would be the
thing that would get the patriots to say
we're not ready to do this they could
always trade for him later they don't
have to do it right now
um maybe they just do a straight gilmore
to someone deal for now and then revisit
the possibility of beckham at a later
date here's one from
fgc081085 we always want to get the
numbers right at the end of a twitter
handle jets quarterback sam darnold and
a third round pick to the bears for the
20th overall pick you know the bears
don't have many options it would be
upgrades over what they currently have i
hadn't thought of sam darnold how does
that pick sound to you who would say no
to that draft uh or that trade
possibility well i think it would be the
the i think it would be the jets right
because are the jets you said the jets
are sending another first round pick
with sam darnold no jets jets get a
first it's it's sam darnold and a three
to the bears for the 20th overall pick
from the bears okay so well then no i
actually i don't know if anybody says no
to that i mean i think the bears maybe
you know you don't necessarily want to
trade your first round pick for sam
darnold but at the same time i think
that that actually gives them a viable
quarterback option
that you know maybe can keep matt neggie
employed right we just talked about that
um with the with the vikings i think the
the biggest thing there is do you
actually believe in sam darnold and do
you believe that he can be the
quarterback for you that can actually
win you some games but i think that that
actually might work out pretty well for
both teams because that means that the
jets could do whatever they want and
getting a quarterback early or they
could wait later in that first round and
then see what quarterback falls to them
or then i mean if you're the bears like
i said you you actually get somebody who
maybe can elevate your offense and can
do things that will help you win rather
than just maybe resigning mitchell
trubisky or seeing what else is out
there on the free agent market or still
rolling the dice with nick foles i don't
really know who says no to that one
actually
yeah it all depends upon what the jets
think of sam darnold and we don't know
because they're not going to come out
and tell us what they really think what
joe douglas isn't going to say it robert
saul is not going to say it uh if they
really like sam darnold that seems a
little bit light to have to give up the
three to get that 20th overall pick back
especially because it doesn't put you in
position to get one of the oh but they
already have the second overall pick so
they could take a quarterback there if
they want i just
there's the and they have they'd have
three first rounders they'd be one short
of the year where they had four first
rounders chad pennington
anthony becht
who were the other two that year in 2000
sean ellis and john abraham uh so one
out of four ain't bad well one and a
half out of four one and a half out of
four i don't know but uh maybe maybe
that's their goal to get four
first-round picks in the 21-year
anniversary of having four first-round
picks in the 2000 draft here's another
one that's related to the bears alex
smith the washington quarterback to
chicago for a fourth round pick miles
who would say no to that
uh
hmm
maybe the bears because i don't know
that i would even want to give up a four
for alex smith i might say if it were a
five then maybe but i i just i don't
know how well alex smith is going to be
able to play you know you don't know how
healthy he's going to be able to stay i
mean he obviously dealt with that calf
strain you know and that's why he
couldn't play in that playoff game with
washington uh i don't know that i want
to give up even a fourth round pick for
somebody who's had those necessarily
health concerns and i don't want to take
anything away from what alex smith was
able to do because obviously he was just
getting him getting back on the field
was terrific for them but i think that
if i'm the bears i want more of a
long-term solution than just what alex
smith would be able to do for me and if
i'm getting alex smith i would have to
have somebody else basically on the
bench getting ready to take over for him
you want alex smith to be a bridge i
don't think you want him to be anybody
that's gonna start more than eight to
ten games for you probably tops if
you're the bears and you make that deal
here's why i say no to this if i'm the
bears alex smith is due to make 18.75
million this year non-guaranteed that's
going to hit the cap as of march 17
washington is not going to pay him that
so
you you wait for alex smith to get cut
and then you go sign him you don't have
to give up anything for him alex smith
isn't going to reduce his his pay he
knows it's his ticket out to free agency
and tampering whether it's in
indianapolis or elsewhere if the bears
are interested in smith
it'll all be pre-planned and that's how
it would go down he gets cut and he
signs with the bears now
taking the trade obligation off the
table if you could just get alex smith
as a free agent would you want to bring
back mitchell trubisky if you're the
bears sign alex smith as a free agent or
do a trade for sam darnold which which
puts them in a better spot in your
opinion for 2021.
i would trade for sam darnold and then
sign alex smith in free agency because
that can i answer the question that way
i'm giving two options instead of just
one
i i i'm fine with that i think that
makes sense and the question then
becomes what kind of a deal could be
done to get sam darnold to chicago but
with matthew stafford off the table not
that he was ever going to the bears with
carson wentz now off the table the bears
have to keep looking and there aren't
many great options out there as they try
to figure out how to upgrade their
quarterback position
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports